ALL DAY.
HE’S DOING IT TONIGHT.
FOR FIVE YEARS, WE HAVE WATCHED
THE NEWS MEDIA TREAT
DONALD TRUMP IN A WAY THAT NO
AMERICAN PRESIDENT HAS EVER BEEN
TREATED.
RICHARD NIXON HIMSELF,
DISGRACED, IMPEACHED, FORCED
FROM OFFICE IN THE END GOT A
PASS BY COMPARISON THE
DONALD TRUMP.
REPORTERS HATE TRUMP WITH AN
ALL-CONSUMING MANIA.
THEY HATE HIM SO INTENSELY THAT
AT TIMES IT’S BEEN AMUSING TO
WATCH.
IF DONALD TRUMP ANNOUNCED A CURE
FOR CANCER, CNN WOULD DENOUNCE
HIM FOR FIXING DRUG PRICES --
THAT’S TRUE.
IF YOU’RE A FAIR-MINDED PERSON,
IT HAS BEEN INFURIATING TO WATCH
THIS, IT’S TOO DISHONEST.
IT’S ALSO PATRONIZING BECAUSE
IT’S ALMOST UNBELIEVABLY STUPID.
"TRUMP WORKS FOR A POLLUTANT,
TRUMP IS A RACIST BECAUSE HE
LIKES BORDERS AND DOESN’T WANT
TO LIVE IN HAITI!"
CLEARLY ALL THE SMART KIDS WENT
INTO FINANCE, THE AMERICAS
WEBSITES TV STATIONS GOT THE
REST.
WE HAVE TO LIVE WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THAT.
WE SHOULD ALSO SAY IF WE ARE
BEING ENTIRELY HONEST THAT AS
GRATING AS ALL OF THIS IS,
UNREMITTING HOSTILITY TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
IS FAR FROM THE GREATEST THREAT
AMERICA FACES.
REPORTERS ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
TOUGH ON PEOPLE WITH POWER,
THAT’S WHY WE HAVE JOURNALISM TO
KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON THOSE WITH
OUTSIZED INFLUENCE ON OUR LIVES.
THE PEOPLE WE SHOULD WATCH
CAREFULLY WOULD INCLUDE BUSINESS
MOGULS, THE INTEL AGENCIES,
PROMINENT ACADEMICS, CULTURAL
FIGURES, MILITARY LEADERS, AND
MOST OBVIOUSLY OUR POLITICIANS.
THE REST OF US CAN’T REALLY KNOW
WHAT THESE PEOPLE, THE PEOPLE IN
CHARGE, ARE DOING AT ALL TIMES.
A REPORTER’S JOB IS TO FIND OUT.
IN THE END, THE REAL THREAT TO
AMERICA ISN’T TOO MANY NASTY
QUESTIONS FROM REPORTERS, IT’S
THE OPPOSITE OF THAT.
THE REAL THREAT IS COLLUSION.
WHEN JOURNALISTS STRIKE SECRET
ALLIANCES WITH THE VERY PEOPLE
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE, WE ARE IN DEEP
TROUBLE.
LIES GO UNCHALLENGED.
DEMOCRACY -- WE LEARNED THE FBI
IS CONDUCTING AN ACTIVE
INVESTIGATION INTO JOE BIDEN’S
SON FOR BUSINESS DEALS THAT
APPARENTLY INCLUDE HIS FATHER,
THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT.
THAT IS NOT SPECULATION, IT IS
CONFIRMED.
A FORMER BIDEN BUSINESS PARTNER
TONY BOBULINSKI SAT WITH A FIVE
HOUR INTERVIEW WITH SIX FBI
AGENTS JUST THE OTHER DAY A WEEK
AGO.
IF THEY ASK HIM ABOUT HIS
BUSINESS DEALINGS IN CHINA WITH
THE BIDEN FAMILY.
WE DON’T KNOW IF THIS
INVESTIGATION WILL RESULT IN
INDICTMENTS, OBVIOUSLY -- WE
KNOW IT COULD.
THAT’S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN IS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
BY ANY POSSIBLE MEASURE, THIS IS
A BLOCKBUSTER STOP THE PRESSES
NEWS STORY.
IT’S NOT SOME NAUGHTY PICTURE
FROM SOMEBODY’S LAPTOP, THIS IS
A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO
BUSINESS DEALS THAT WE KNOW FOR
A FACT JOE BIDEN WAS PARTY TO,
WHY HAVEN’T YOU HEARD MORE ABOUT
THIS?
IF YOU DON’T WATCH THIS CHANNEL,
YOU’VE LIKELY HEARD NOTHING AT
ALL, NOT A WORD AND YOU KNOW WHY
BECAUSE THE MEDIA ARE
COLLABORATING.
THEY ARE COLLABORATING WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY ARE
COLLABORATING WITH THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES THAT SPY
ON AMERICANS WITH IMPUNITY.
THEY ARE COLLABORATING WITH THE
TECH MONOPOLIES THAT HAVE CHOKED
OFF THE AVERAGE PERSON’S ACCESS
TO LEGITIMATE INFORMATION.
WE AREN’T OVERSTATING ANY OF
THAT, WE WISH WE WERE.
WATCH THE PEOPLE WE ARE SUPPOSED
TO BE ABLE TO TRUST DISMISS A
COMPLETELY LEGITIMATE, VERIFIED
NEWS STORY AS "A RUSSIAN PLOT."
>> HOLDING SUPER-SPREADER EVENTS
AND GIVING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION, SPREADING
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION.
>> DISINFORMATION THAT HE KNOWS
TO BE FABRICATED AND SUPPLIED BY
A FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
AND DESPITE THE WARNING, HE
STILL DOING IT.
>> THIS ENTIRE THING IS SO
OBVIOUSLY A RUSSIAN PLOT.
>> IT’S SORT OF A CRAZY QUILT AT
THIS POINT WHICH HAS ALL THE
HALLMARKS OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
THAT SAID, IT WASN’T FOR LACK OF
TRYING.
>> BASICALLY FUNCTIONING AS A
RUSSIAN ASSET BY PUSHING RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
>> THE AUTHORITIES ARE SEEING IF
THOSE EMAILS ARE CONNECTED TO AN
ONGOING RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
EFFORT.
THIS >> Tucker: IT HAS ALL THE
HALLMARKS OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION.
THESE PEOPLE WOULDN’T KNOW
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION IF IT GOT
INTO THE SHOWER WITH THEM, THEY
KNOW NOTHING.
EVERY WORD OF WHAT THEY JUST
SAID IS A LIE.
RUSSIA DIDN’T FORGE THESE
EMAILS, VLADIMIR PUTIN DIDN’T
INVENT THE TWO SEPARATE MEETINGS
THAT TONY BOBULINSKI HAD WITH
JOE BIDEN TO DISCUSS BUSINESS
WITH JOE BIDEN.
THAT’S ALL ENTIRELY REAL, IT
HAPPENED, IT IS HAPPENING NOW
AND THE PEOPLE YOU JUST WATCHED
ON THE SCREEN KNOW THAT IT DID.
YET THEY ARE TELLING YOU IT’S
ALL FAKE, A CONCOCTION OF A
HOSTILE FOREIGN POWER.
YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF AT SOME
POINT, WHY WOULD THEY TELL YOU
THAT?
THEY KNOW IT’S NOT TRUE, THEY
ARE SAYING IT ANYWAY.
THEY ARE EXPECTING YOU TO
BELIEVE IT, WHY ARE THEY DOING
THAT?
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT YOUR
ALLIES.
THEY ARE NOT TRYING TO HELP YOU
OR INFORM YOU, JUST THE
OPPOSITE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE YOUR ENEMIES.
THEY ARE MISLEADING YOU SO YOU
WILL OBEY.
MAYBE IT WILL WORK, MAYBE THEY
WILL GET JOE BIDEN ELECTED
PRESIDENT WITHOUT EVEN ASKING
THE MOST BASIC QUESTIONS OR
BETTING THEM IN ANY WAY.
THAT CAN WORK, IT’S A GAMBIT,
BUT WHAT THEN?
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE YOU JUST
SAW ON THE SCREEN WILL GO TO
WORK FOR BIDEN OFFICIALLY, WE
WOULD EXPECT THAT BECAUSE
WITHOUT DONALD TRUMP TO
HYPERVENTILATE OVER, THE
BUSINESS MODELS AT MANY NEWS
OUTLETS WILL COLLAPSE AND THESE
PEOPLE WILL NEED JOBS.
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
CAN’T HIRE EVERYONE AT NBC, SOME
OF THESE PEOPLE HAVE TO CONTINUE
TO BE "JOURNALISTS."
AND THE QUESTION IS CAN THEY
REALLY DO THAT?